[Music]
are you ready
what are we doing
we're gonna run for our lives
we're halfway home halfway i'm chicky
donahue and i am not supposed to be in
vietnam
hey your ass out of bed you later look
at you sleeping your life away
look at these scumbags
you're embarrassing yourself and you're
embarrassing your family do these
protesters not know that our soldiers
see that on tv i'd like to go over to
vietnam track down all the boys in the
neighborhood and give them a bit i could
do that do what bringing beer he's not
serious he's hammered look at him the
man stoned sober that's his fifth beer
maybe tops i'm going to vietnam and i'm
bringing him beer
hey chief no chance you have a ship
heading to vietnam 1700 hours tonight
it's not gonna be easy but i'm gonna
show him that this country is still
behind him you're gonna get yourself
killed over there it's like you said
everyone's doing something
i'm doing nothing
smuggling beer into a war zone that's
not the smartest thing i've ever heard
of it's certainly not the worst either a
new day
what if you start up here with collins
this came to deliver a sudsy thank you
card and then if you're still alive
you american new york thanks a lot you
can hustle down to dugan
[Applause]
tricky i brought you beer
you shouldn't be here you think this is
funny
i'm not doing this for laughs i'm doing
it for all you guys
come on time to go
is it over
yeah you're dead
[Applause]
you don't get it do you chick this isn't
a john wayne movie where you know the
good guys on you know the bad guys are
i didn't come all this way just to quit
somebody's got to be here see what's
going on
i want the truth told for them
they're just kids
you're gonna find out it's a lot harder
to get out of a war than it is to get
into one i'm trying to show them that
somebody back home is still behind her
you got a good heart chicky it's your
brains i'm worried about
[Applause]
who's this [ __ ] it's my next door
neighbor he brought me a beer
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
you